hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the escapists is a very
very very very very often requested game
so I'm going to check it out and see it
for myself
considering I'm preparing four packs I'm
just going to try to find the one that
represents me the mahjong buck I like it
young and in prison don't know I don't
know how don't care I guess I do need
the tutorial because I have no idea how
to play this game I know that it
involves getting out of prison so move
your desk and left click to open it you
got it bro screwdriver why do I have
that why do I have a sock - just one oh
I don't want to know I don't want to
know ok
whoa how do I step inside my oh oh I
stepped up oh that's cool
ok this might be a bit more complicated
than I thought there we go
ok ah that's cool ok so I got the
screwdriver it wants me to unscrew that
go up in the vent which is conveniently
placed above my cell left click no that
was my bed iPod I'm not no come on
behave there okay left clicking on it oh
I see on the vent itself I thought it
meant like the general vent that was
around it okay
once you make it make your way to a
nearby cell this one my physically my
buddy
or am I just gonna end up bashing this
guy's skull in alright huh hello-o
Durden his name's Durnin did you need
something
yeah I decide drop into your cell in the
middle of the day in full view of that
security guard over there open his
profile unemployed why would he be
employed anyway well I guess prisoners
do have jobs some time craft away I can
craft a weapon out of a screwdriver soap
and a sock what can I possibly make okay
then so I would get out of dirt ins no I
get out of there we go
crafting oh-oh-oh whirly suck or
whatever you call it you know where you
put a soap in a sock and you beat people
with it it's the best weapon I sock mace
oh of course
what was I thinking I was thinking of
something technical sock mace how do I
get out of this menu young buck
unemployed very strong speedy and
intelligent so now I have a weapon press
space to toggle combat mode on and off
with a click the garden target him hey
hey I got a sock mace come closer so I
can smack you with it please okay what
well alright then I think I think I have
it but I don't know why was the door
open yeah don't mind me officer fragile
I'm just gonna bash your skull in boom
oh no oh no oh no is he dead oh he's
just unconscious okay grab his outfit
yeah this is gonna work out great
no one's gonna recognize me at all okay
so if I take this uh-huh okay head to
the right head north past the guards
goodbye everybody
yeah you keep enforcing the law don't
don't mind this hole in the ground
what Oh I mean thinks this tutorial
isn't very realistic at all is this the
hole where they put people and saw in
solitary confinement okay dig upwards in
the merge underground I can't
get on an empties Oh huh huh digging on
an empty space allows you to oh okay
okay God there's some like up-down
dynamic in this 2d perspective this
reminds me a lot of earthbound lay it
looks very much like earthbound so it's
kind of confusing me okay we're gonna be
on to the real game I'm a master right
now rename characters oh my god I can
rename characters uh Bob let's see uh
Oh one of the guards to be weighed ah
you'll be way know you'll be um you you
have me marry miss search you'll be you
have immerse oh god dammit the but
you'll be burb okay enter there we go
you Harmon nourish diff okay this is
going to be jig Sam to dig Jeff's head
to take and this is gonna be uh cinnamon
CN and Mon you got it I guess God do
glar do gears okay I'm just naming up
random youtubers that I know
machee I met bad majesty this this
stance sorry Mathias see uh ego bum bum
rah
and did he end any and this guy's wave
cuz I want to bash him in the fix I'm
just kidding wait I'm actually probably
when you're watching this I'm hanging
out with wave right now at PAX South so
that's probably good dear young buck
welcome to Center perks the most
comfortable low security prison in the
country County on behalf of all the
staff here we wish you a happy and
relaxing visit should you get bored of
the complimentary cable TV we pride
ourselves in many other engaging
activities around the grounds
sincerely warden Albert L Valero whose
place seems kind of great why would I
want to leave well I'm a young buck so
obviously I'll get bored
whoa prison life is all about routine
wait what am i doing I can't move well
I'm stuck okay
routine don't mind me officer Wade quiet
please yes can I help you officer what
hey those due to a cell shake on
cinnamon on and do gears in here life is
easy if your name is pulled from a
shakedown to roll call make sure your
desk is free of contraband we've only
gone and been given another award the
warden may be visiting today is that the
warden naughty boys will be sent to sue
I wouldn't want to be a naughty boy
officer Wade oh you would never do that
you're all do a pat on the back
someone broke into the storage shed whoa
what the hell was that
what happened wait what what happened a
pat on the back is a good thing why
would they do that if someone broke in -
what is going on performing a manual
test will raise your fatigue you can
lower it by eating showering and
breastfeed your dad from there I don't
know what you doin this routine is
foreign to me okay I got a food tray I'm
gonna eat with my buddy Danny Danny
Danny let me eat with you I wasn't
carrying anything illegal okay so I
apologize while I get adjusted this game
it's not gonna look very good on me
but I'm gonna get there okay so I just I
accidentally switched to combat mode
when I was trying to interact with Danny
trying to I was just trying to sit down
and meet with my friend and it all went
horribly wrong
employment officer uh sir okay
laundry young buck kitchen
Janusz mid jab scepter dig is in the
metal shaft okay cool so what is my
routine right now is there a way to
check like exactly what I'm supposed to
do and it doesn't look like it I guess
the routines are over for today Sydney
and Mon am i boring you
no not really the guards are more
crooked than cons they seem actually
really nice to me I've been working on
my 1-inch fun good job brew Ross
actually has taken like stuff my wife's
a visiting when she heard okay anyway so
which one was my cell I believe it was
this let me just see if there's anything
in my bow there's a lot of stuff okay so
got all these stuff green items are
legal red litems are illegal hello
officer Owen oh my me was this oh that's
solitary confinement okay I'm just
getting adjusted with everything some
tips okay so I guess from here on it's
just Oh what happened to you go bum bum
I'll just take all hood stuff don't mind
me uh alright then how do I can i craft
i don't know what i can craft so i'm not
exactly sure what I should be doing I've
got one item that is illegal a spatula a
comb is totally fired by the spatula Oh
heard officer Owens wife ran off with
another man well that's sad I guess but
what do I need to do about that my Lord
paid me bro played me bro okay sorry can
I just walk out the front door is that a
thing if you can do no all right
there's got to be something else around
here that I can take advantage of
whoa Oh lunch okay thank God that
freaked me out
well so why was the random anime just
smacked in the head Bop like a really
little bunny I don't know he's got to be
something else unless I need to follow
the routine for now I'm very new at this
game and I'm not gonna be able to take
your advice because I'm gonna be at PAX
and all this is gonna be pre-recorded Oh
keep up pick up the pace young buck I'm
trying where are you going what pace to
I need okay
oh no oh no they beat up do gir Luger no
Luger do gir trowel
let's do grab a trowel tub of talcum
powder roll of toilet paper roll of duct
tape well it seems like a bunch of stuff
I can uh I know you didn't know you
didn't know you didn't know you didn't
know you didn't Oh get away from me -
yeah he'll just give up the chase
prisoner gypsum tub whatever okay so I
gotta do my job quota
okay so inventory is full inventory full
whoa okay so if I drop my stuff off in
my desk then I'll be able to finish him
that's horrible
ah toilet Oh probably not the best place
have mercy
I'm Rosie drop that fool why I'm not a
fool ow what was that did I get shot oh
man this prison is not his low security
as I thought it was okay so I'll have
another opportunity to get more
contraband I just need to not loot it in
the middle of you know everything okay
can I not can I not do I have to
manually do this I've done manually do
this oh I can press the numbers up okay
Wow I thought that guy was beating me I
thought he was just smacking me in the
face like what I do officer this is real
prison all right this is really exciting
to watch is doing laundry the best this
is what prison life is all about
everybody don't go to prison you'll be
called POW and Buddy and then they'll
all pat you on the back I don't need
this crap crap
how do I drop to crap I guess I could
take one of these now that I'm thinking
about I could take one of these guard
outfits yeah I'm gonna take one of the
clean ones if they don't have anything
to say about it yeah I don't think they
do why can't I pick that up
can I pick that up now all right
whatever let's go stay on the ground
then why do I have to do a job quota
anyway whoa thanks thanks for picking
that up for me buddy well so why would
they put a cut a prisoner just in charge
of all the laundry for the cops uniforms
if that's definitely something that
needed to be controlled exercise framed
it was Billy Bob Joe again with the
bullet to the face what did I do
mixed up the blood test results oh man
this is nuts
this is nuts I didn't do a damn thing I
didn't do a damn thing I got framed salt
bowl okay do we deliver see shift young
buck does that mean does that mean
you're gonna I wasn't even done yet
shower brawl showering together
well it seems highly irregular but here
we go there's a perimeter around here
yeah no joke they're all watching
officer Wade why are you watching the
inmates shower what see can't be unseen
alright bye I guess hurry young buck
what's it mean do I need to be here or
else oh oh I see okay oh so there's a
cop meter I apologize if I'm new to this
everything is foreign to me and I'm
trying to figure it out as best I can
totally new to the game so bear with me
by the end of this series I'm gonna be
an expert evening meal good I haven't
eaten anything all day I'm so hungry
officers I'm just having the time of my
life here in prison don't mind me at all
me first and there we go whoo my jab
step dude EGH Jeremy Manchin barb I love
this company
let me just shove it into my face hold a
little bit I'm actually eating her am i
just holding it in front of my face okay
you guys stink so well alright then
Duggars just gonna take a little nap
over there even in free time which means
I should be able to grab what's on dude
you're right about now funk soul brother
I'm gonna put this in my damn thing
they're not after me are they no they're
not not this time I'm too smart from no
no no don't do that
desk okay so actually none of this oh
dude you're had a pedicure kid that's
adorable um I guess I could just put all
this stuff in here I know there's gotta
be something that I can craft but I
don't know like if there's a crafting
list or something like that I don't have
that information I'm just gonna have to
do it by trial and error maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe I could
look it up on these computers or
something intellect browsing good great
does that mean I get more recipes I can
see my energy meter is filling up that's
good I guess
maybe possibly I don't know I guess I'm
just getting tired I haven't actually
done any work
maybe I'll go work out a bit more maybe
then blast my quads a little bit don't
mind me just got naked for a while nope
that ain't right all right how do I rep
I know it said thought it was I thought
I said AMD but apparently not oh okay
okay
alternate Q&E that was it look at me go
I'm so strong
everybody impressed is everybody's super
impressed at my giant muscles this day
is totally gone to waste I will readily
admit that but tomorrow I'm gonna have a
plan I'm gonna get it done
but get it really done guys I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna get it probably maybe they
up turf to my entire cell I don't know
what that means man I don't know your
prison lingo just trying to be me just
let me be me I steal stuff from other
people's desks mad Tibetans good we
didn't roll duct tape yes
plastic goodnight hell yeah file holy
hell yeah let's take that no one saw
nothing I just stole from another
prisoner I just stole the screw in the
tuna George people remember Kenan and
Kel okay I'm stealing from new girl
again that's okay she won't mind I guess
Danny Danny what have you got ten dildos
Oh cookie I'm taking Danny's cookie
there's no way Danny would ever want
that one more time and then I'm gonna go
Rouge okay another roll of duct tape
another thing is soap
that'll do me that'll do me okay desk
but that way that way that way that way
there's gotta be something that I can
craft from all that but I'm pretty sure
that it's the end of the day so I'm
gonna have to get to it in the next
episode after we go through this ordeal
here don't worry officer I'll be
reporting for duty lend me your ears
lucky winner of today's shake that it
better not be me
most escape his return here by choice
someone devoured all the custard creams
well isn't that some important
information the prisoner is always right
well thank you very much the prisoner is
always right thank you for reiterating
that points very important don't be
afraid yeah I want a hug right now
officer why'd some exciting news for you
all
huh sadly our karaoke machine is
knackered that's not exciting news are
you talking about weirdo alright so
tomorrow plan my escape I plan my epic
escape because I've got all the
materials so anyway let me just pause
here so thank you all so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this in the comments below unfortunately
I won't be able to change anything that
I'm doing until I get back from pax but
I hope to see you guys there if you're
currently seeing me right now like
immediately you're watching this and
you're coming up and saying hi to me
that's really cool cuz this is in the
future so give me this message in the
future
Marc you're a big girl mediate you did
everything wrong in this episode
everyone's mad at you and you should
know better about a game that you just
started playing and don't know anything
about how dare you so tell me that when
you're watching this right now go up to
me if you need to go up to me right now
I'll give you time go up to me have you
found me okay tell me that those things
I said so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the other videos
that I've done the description below or
in the annotation over there
as always I will see you in the next
video
mean